in memory of Jim Henson here's a
low-rent turtle sequel complete with the
vanilla ice salt why is this movie
acting like the first movie made eating
pizza in New York I think this would be
like Caddyshack - acting like an
embedded golf which one of you lucky
girls gets a ride with me tonight this
kid never learned the cardinal rule of
employment never hit on anyone at work
especially if you deliver pizza well
what I do I'll dream with something a
little thinner movie promotes fat
shaming also this kid's life hold it huh
you guys are under arrest
seriously you guys are under arrest this
teenage martial arts master is still
delivering pizzas these other thieves
didn't even hear all the commotion
outside so they could be surprised dicks
also who plans to rob an entire mall
with the lights on and how many thieves
signed on to rob this place are we sure
it's not a flash mob also this kid has
very little to worry about this is
anything like the last movie all these
guys will take turns trying to fight Oh
acting how did these assholes hear about
the robbery in progress oh they live
right across the street now
how convenient good even though these
turtle mutants were created in the
sewers of New York they have Southern
California accents with the exception of
Raphael
collected cheese did this movie just get
self-referential also his bizarre word
choice just robbed Michelangelo if his
turn to say a word Donatello reminds us
that rawhide and Robocop existed for no
reason where does he think he is in a
future DreamWorks movie wait wait wait
wait they wait so here comes that great
debate are these stupid criminals or are
they criminally stupid I admit there's
no wrong answer you know when you can
tell you're in an imitation sandwich
shop they misspelled Reuben get ready
for all the random guys the turtles
fight throughout this movie to do a lot
of standing around oh wow where well
that leaves a why and when doesn't it
kids love journalism humor didn't they
say they were gonna tie them up
looks like they suddenly got lazy and
just stack them up wait hey really our
team's stealing is bad kids so if you
take something that doesn't belong to
you leave a few bucks behind I know you
you're uh uh April on April O'Neil yeah
the news lady
awkward character introduction also new
actress grocery bag has a large bag at
hanging out of it cliche
Langella leonardo Donatello and Raphael
pranks comics skateboarding and working
out our convenient personality markers
in case you can't remember which turtle
wears which color mask also April agreed
to let the turtles and splinter crash at
her place what's more the extremely
cautious splinter seems to be okay with
this arrangement to putting April in
more danger also what happened to Casey
Jones didn't they force-feed that
romance to us in the last movie whoa
pretty much work out they're constantly
feeling the need to make some sort of
mouth sound it's the absolute opposite
of being discreet which is one of the
main rules of being a ninja and one of
the primary things splinter asks you to
do
Michelangelo's pizza should look like a
hot mess based on all this shaking but
it seems totally fine we brought it in
that's racist ninja pizza picks up that
banish quickly without trace it's also
resistant a trap it's a little tough
what about 500 members of that Foot Clan
know where you live you knows right what
you know I took the time to rewatch the
first movie to make sure I'd know what
was going on when I watch this one but
it's clear to me now that was totally
unnecessary she was just getting up here
earlier about the house being messy yet
here she is contributing to the problem
wasn't shredder brutally compacted at
the end of the last movie I mean sure
this is a work of fiction where anything
can happen but he was brutally compacted
right is the old recuperate in a
landfill trick also evil persons hand
reaching out of the ground cliche she's
the best man from those that may follow
the reporter
movie basically just explained why the
turtles and splinter living at April's
apartment is the dumbest thing ever it's
nice to find a company that's doing
something to help its techno global
research industries spokesman Professor
Jordan Perry April is a reporter anymore
she now does televised press releases
excuse me professor did April now prep
the professor for this interview it's
entirely possible he doesn't know about
it and she's just bothering him at work
hey Paul is it more entertaining or more
annoying that Michelangelo is eating a
bread stick at a decibel level that is
beyond impossible and obviously boosted
in post-production for maximum annoyance
this is supposed to be funny because
it's happening to ruff I know but it's
also actually happening to us I can
still hear it what exactly is he
referring to he has no ears
would you mind if I asked you a bottle
another tool Oh drat you know we're
gonna have to do it another time good
cover professor no one suspects that you
just made that up oh we gonna well I
don't know based on that interview in
this line of questioning I'm not sure
she's qualified to be a journalist got
to take care of this now did this guy
think Little Shop of Horrors was a
documentary if not I don't really
understand his urgency area that is
explicitly off-limits to the general
public is poorly guarded cliche Danny
Lyons what he meant to say was giant
plastic flower this guy basically runs
out into the open with the secret giant
dandelion and somehow nobody in this
group of workers sees him I mean
shredder was compacted right
my wife Pam really spoiled our surprise
by coming home to your house
join me above there's no reason they
couldn't have this meeting in the living
room failed by a shadow too deep to
penetrate annoyed by the metaphor to mix
to parse huh oh it's just a glass tube
carry on teach your eye splinter has
never bothered to do any research into
their origins whatsoever this isn't a
new company and though there wasn't
Google back in the day there was a thing
called a phone book and this major
corporation in that area was certainly
listed I knew that there was something
else going on with those guys what they
cleaning up toxic sludge this doesn't
seem like too far leap pyramids are the
most scientific of all the shapes well
you're the last one aren't you
I say as shredders men come running into
the secret lab to steal use the
databases coated the whole system Ike
went down this line was written by
someone who doesn't know how computers
work quick everyone get into position
behind the turtles rather than just
going ahead and kicking their asses
right now why would you show them the
canister
why aren't you halfway to Shredder's
lair yet Michelangelo throws a jar and
it knocks the canister out of this guy's
hand so far that Donatello can catch it
these guys standing on the computers are
patiently waiting their turn to have
their ass kicked or they are the worst
touring company of the Rockettes I have
ever seen this is highly sensitive
material no one seems to be concerned
about breaking it this huddle seems like
the perfect time for the foot to get the
upper hand but they seem to be
comfortable just standing around the
scene was a lot better when they did it
in the great Muppet Caper ninja vanish
it's very helpful to tell the enemy
exactly what you're about to do that's
why James Bond is always yelling spy
shoot first we move then we look they
have to make sure they give the bad guys
enough time to make some terrible
creatures I didn't order any pizza oh I
know what the guy in 313 did and now he
doesn't seem to be there so I'll take
this opportunity to barge in because I'm
a licensed pizza delivery guy and why
doesn't April tell this guy to cop
anyway does this happen often I thought
you might want to know about they claim
to be ninjas but they aren't great
hiders couldn't they have just gone
upstairs or something I gave them all
names because you barged in and noticed
us and fainted we're going to tell you
everything now
Raphael just flip us off we what you're
telling me is you guys
we're all slimed hmm it wasn't slime
if we zoom someone forgot to teach me
the difference between slime and ooze
that's an indictment on the American
school system and Georgie immense desert
conveniently time thunderclap is
convenient this is another example of
the turtles continued failure to conceal
themselves when out in public have lives
and two people don't amount to a hill of
beans in this crazy world Elsa is this
Bogart by way of a sped-up Peter Falk
also 90s teens love Bogart impressions
does that stained-glass ceiling have
access to daylight yeah sneezing without
a nose I'm not too worried about this
thing I feel like if it was actually
powerful it would have ripped this
flimsy enclosure apart by now business
ponytail does it detached pay phone have
cell phone capabilities this far
underground this abandoned subway
station has electricity and working
phone lines hella behind sounds will no
longer hold over well those aren't cells
it's just a pile of hastily stacked
garbage you can't do that living
creatures I mean kind of all these guys
gonna have to take a little test dead if
you good enough we let you into the
organization you've got to fight each
other in a no-holds-barred karate kid'
tournament considering the sheer number
of people in the Foot Clan there's no
way all these assholes want tournaments
to get it but hey it kind of sounds good
for the plot of the specific movie right
I knew this would work just remember
when you win we find a foot headquarters
um yeah why would you forget that why is
he potentially blowing his cover by
coming to meet you during the initiation
and even worse this guy even
acknowledges that after they talk holy
this is stupid
I don't think the dude in the glasses is
the sort of teenager they're looking for
on account of him being 35 you seem to
be the only one worthy of a final test
you'll have 15 seconds remove as many of
the bells as you can the final test for
this potential Foot Clan soldier is to
steal bells off a mannequin quickly
without making noise you know common
real-world applications you run into all
the time as a thief who knows martial
arts also now I'm absolutely certain
there shouldn't be a lot of Foot Clan
soldiers after seeing these tests any
more than say 15 is pushing it I mean
seriously
all these dumbasses passed the belt test
come on all these assholes wait while
Raphael gives this kid a message visible
butt pads we could run across something
iconic and picturesque also damn this
kid ran all the way back to Manhattan
hasn't he ever heard of the subway Mike
April April takes time out of her busy
reporting schedule to be an ex back it
up
until the guys they got him keno plays
the pronoun game so that April has to
ask who they are that's a remarkably
effective
remind me to draw a line around later
out there that's a reference for the
parents spoon turd with a bow and arrow
X mock it up why did you just rip my
lips saw so many footplant soldiers and
yet they're apparently all fighting
Michelangelo and Leonardo right now and
allowing Donatello to save Raphael also
you see Foot Clan soldiers running by
them this entire scene why did you just
rip my lips saw turtle character
references a thing normal humans have on
the face but mutant turtles do not it
really takes the fun out of it to watch
action scenes like this where the
soldiers are so dumb they stand around
and watch individual fights and this
happens right after they surround
Raphael and captured him in the last
scene like a good army would do they are
almost the same size as you Splinter is
able to show up just at the right times
whenever is needed but no explanation as
to how he got there of course the bora
trees were crude back then and an
accident was just waiting to happen way
back in 1976 laboratories were still
stuck in 1883 you mean to tell us if the
formation of the UNS was all just a big
mistake
why is donnie so surprised it's clear
that his entire existence is a mistake
right well on our way to bury them in
their collision caused us to lose one of
the canisters down a sewer 15 years ago
but just one it was the only canister we
didn't secure with over bands and scotch
tape in the back of our El Camino it
ain't they helped let's face it you'd be
better off staying in the Hilton
wouldn't most people that's really the
whole reason you said it ain't the
Hilton in the first place right power
lines that have one wire on them what
did these old people doing in the seedy
alley in the middle of the night I can
only assume they're here to pick up some
heroin is this guy trying to figure out
how they pulled the poles down by
tugging on this wire or is he just
trying to look like he's working because
this is actually a kids movie filled
with bad actors there is no choice but
to meet as the Shred though wishes I'd
say there are several choices go tell
the police so they can block off the
area set a series of traps stay in neat
pizza it's just trying to force you guys
into fighting toka and Ross are again
how does she know their names I've seen
more of those creatures than she has and
I didn't even know their names
to be fair I'm not sure what the pizza
delivery boys name is Kibo roulette and
the potion is still going to work after
this movie science - not so subtly
integrate a message about
recycling into the movie at the last
minute don't have a Cowabunga man they
wait yes it is they'll eat anything how
do you know this what the fuck why would
they put them in ice cubes and then I
guess shove them into doughnuts instead
of just using the stuff as batter or a
glaze it clearly just needed a way to
have the bad guys find out their plan so
they could have another fight scene why
don't you all take the ugly one or at
least two of you in the middle of this
fight movie takes time to take in a
vanilla ice concert also this club book
Vanilla Ice one of the most popular
entertainers at the time it would
probably not be performing in some
random club can he hear the background
music yo it's the Green Machine gonna
rock the town without bein seen suddenly
he knows enough about the turtles to rap
about them why are these people watching
Vanilla Ice instead of the mutant animal
fight happening right behind them
that's good Riverdance I oxide is
essential to the answer using the genic
process I guess one ice cube and that
stuff was enough to start this reaction
so why did they make so much of it
earlier I know you're trying to help me
but you can't keep me here you know he's
also just a sewer rat who should know
nothing about martial arts even if this
doesn't speed up the reaction squirting
a fire extinguisher in their mouth will
surely kill them anyway
if this guy's so easy to defeat why
didn't they do this shell smashing trick
earlier shredder stands there
dumbfounded with his special canister of
ooze while a pizza delivery kid kicks it
out of his hands tritter is the most
useless bad guy in existence he's
basically Darth Vader without any
intelligence or the Force time for me to
get emotionally invested in some woman
in the club who we don't know could they
have figured out a way to get April in
the club so he could kidnap her making
the stakes a little higher and she could
have fallen in love with vanilla ice
what well now these adorable animals are
going to die because they pump
compressed co2 into their mouths
viola balloons he must have drank all of
it the is also upgraded his outfit
because you know science well he is
still just as dumped because him
knocking on all these post is going to
cause the deck to collapse nobody could
have survived that says the guy who saw
shredder get compacted in the last movie
also where's he getting his facts it
would have hurt like hell but he is
wearing armor and seemed pretty
plausible that he would survive well ok
then he didn't survive or didn't he when
did a people get the anger job I thought
she was a field reporter
he sounds pretty insistent says his
name's Danny this you can tell Oh
all right either
fear leads to anger anger leads to hate
hate leads to suffering major spin
psycho you know that knew fouls you
looking for well listen to this